today's episode is brought to you by
liquid death
you'll be surprised it's water
today's episode is brought to you by
magic mind
procrastination is a thing of the past
with this beautiful sipper go to
magicmind.co and use code
theo magic for 20 off
flow state now comes in a bottle
today's guest is uh well he's a
he's a soundtrack of a lot of a lot of
lives
many lives and he's um i mean just a
real archipelago of talent
um you know i really my god i just
well you'll hear all about it i'm
honored to uh to be able to be in his
presence today
and to uh to uh have a conversation
with the um musical superhero
mr travis tripped
[Music]
[Applause]
and how's it been like having kids like
is was it was it hard to go from like
being a kid because i feel like with
fame and popularity there's this
you know when i can't imagine your
position in my position i notice a
little bit there's more
opportunity to stay a kid yeah right
things are just
you know life there's more fun going on
you're part of the fun you're bringing
the fun
was it hard to go from that to like
wanting to be like a parent and getting
into that vibe like was that was that
ever a thing
it you know it was a process it um
i got married right out of high school
and did what everybody else did you
either
did one of two things you either went to
college which that wasn't
an option for me damn no judgment bro
you know
college is hard exactly or you got
married and went to work
so i got married to my high school
sweetheart
and went to work for heating and air
conditioning wholesale company down in
georgia
so was that hvac were you getting in the
attics or were you just selling the
equipment i was selling the equipment
okay but i was also going to school
like uh two or three times a year to
find out
all of the you know updated products and
kind of be a troubleshooter
you know for for all the products so
i did that and i started out on the
docks loading trucks and worked my way
up to
manager of the store for in about 18
months
damn and were you a hard worker uh yeah
i mean
well that's right around that same time
is when i started
wanting to play music as well and so
that
marriage lasted for about two and a half
years
and as soon as that marriage was over um
i started playing clubs at night
and then six days a week monday through
saturday and then i would play
i would go and get get up the next
morning and go and do my gig so it
that nearly killed me even though i was
very young right it nearly killed me
just those hours and do you think if you
had stayed married in that first
marriage would you think you think you
would have had the same career was there
inspiration that came out of getting
a separation at that young age was it
were you just too young to even
be able to put any of that any of those
feelings into music didn't he
i wouldn't even have thought about it
probably at that particular
time thought about music yeah as a
full-time gig
i mean i played occasionally with you
know i had a little band that i played
with you know every now and then but
not very often and uh i was kind of
my wife at the time she kind of
discouraged me from doing that
too because you know when you're a
new young couple yeah you don't want
your husband out
you know running around all over the
place man yeah and it's not even
look play doing a live performance it's
not a real job to people until you start
to really make it i feel like that's
right
i mean until then you're just a really
you're just somebody who's trying to
break up marriages around the area
i feel like like people are like this
[ __ ] is a little strange
it's a good analogy it really is so but
that whole thing just
uh it just worked out and i
i did i did the day job and the night
job
for oh i don't know several eight months
maybe and i started realizing that i was
having more fun at my night job
than i was at my day job and oddly
enough i was making more money
at my night job my day so i
went back to my my uh vice president
and said look you know if i don't take
this shot now
i'll never know i'll end up being an old
man one day and i'll never know
whether or not i could have made it in
the in the music industry so i
i quit that job and and never looked
back
was there a person that kind of like
chatted with you and influenced you
my best friend scott's dad actually he
introduced me to jerry clower who i was
telling you about is one of my favorite
comedians
and um and just a storyteller you know i
just miss
so often now we everything's glanced
over the art of storytelling and it's
all just like uh
almost like everything's an equation of
what sells you know and
um and jerry clower just did it he just
put me in a comfortable place but
my friend my best friend when i was
young his dad
was from mississippi and he introduced
me to jerry clower and then he said to
me one day
i said you know i think about doing
stand-up comedy and he goes well you
have to go do it you know you have to go
and take that chance because
otherwise it's your life will be there
you can always come back
you know was there anybody like that in
you that kind of
or was it just you playing that kind of
influenced you to keep moving
the uh vice president of the heating and
air conditioning wholesale company
that i told you about he also was a
really good guitar player
and he had had of course it was a kind
of a family business and
his uh his whole family his dad had been
president of the company and
they had groomed him to basically do
that but
when he was very young i think he had an
offer from carlos santana to go out on
the road
and play guitar with carlos santana
that's huge he's
wonderful and he passed it up oh and so
when i went to
him and told him about what my dreams
were he's like man do it
because he said i will be that guy in my
rocking chair
at however however old 80 years old
wondering man i wonder if i could have
if i could have made it in the music
industry man and he gave me
he also gave me a kind of a safety net
because he said look man if it doesn't
work
your job here is always safe so i knew
something i had something to fall back
on
yeah but it worked out great man i mean
it was just it seemed like you're doing
it seemed like
it's paid off for you yeah you know from
an outsider's perspective
um do you uh do you miss sometimes like
um
like i've gotten to some light levels of
success in in my
work in the past few years and and it's
been a long series of work
but it's kind of weird i felt like when
i got to a certain level of like uh
like mild popularity or comfort like
that every all my problems would go away
right or other things would disappear
but really you're just still right there
oh it's it's it those things never
change
you know and the more success that you
do have
first of all the busier you are yeah you
know i remember the first two years
when i started releasing records in in
1989
the first two years i was home
each year a total of 14 days each year
and no two days were ever together thea
they they were all
it was just like one day here because
you're either
you're either writing or recording or
you're out on the road performing
concerts or
you're doing videos or doing press or
doing whatever
yeah and it's every single day when it
takes off like that
um it just it's every single day and
i don't have the luxury of being
travis tritt uh 40 hours a week right
you know why wouldn't it be nice
wouldn't it be nice you could you lock
out at a certain hour
it would be man you're like all right
i'm just donny tripp
you know what i'm saying joe schmoe
yeah yeah wouldn't that be nice that
would be great out of it
it'd be great but on the other side of
that coin
i found that for me the old saying about
find something that you love to do and
find a way to make a living with it and
you'll never work a day in your life
and that's really true for me i mean you
know yeah there's
there's it's not all glitz and
a lot of people out there think it's
celebrity all the time and they think
it's glitz and glamour and all this
stuff
but that's that's not it at all as a
matter of fact
when i come home a lot of people that
that i correspond with through social
media or whatever
they think that the only people that i
hang out with
are celebrities right right or people in
that
and that's the furthest thing in the
world from the truth in my case
i go back home when i get off the road i
go back home
and hang out with people that i've known
for some of them i've known since high
school that's cool
and like 30 years you know and they're
all every single one of them
you know these are not they're not even
involved in the entertainment industry i
mean they're
most of them are blue-collar
hard-working people that go out and work
with their hands
and uh they keep me grounded
they keep me grounded if i if i came
back home and started
acting anything other than the travis
that they know
and have known for all these years man
they wouldn't hesitate in one second
oh man put me right back in my place
exactly exactly
was there a time like because yeah it's
a rot when things get busy especially in
you guys's world like it is
it's such a rocket ship i mean i did
about a year and a half of touring and
it was so intense like
around the world and it was just intent
it was just like there were countries i
don't even remember being in
right really and this happened a year
and a half you know it's just like yeah
it's almost bizarre kind of just the the
pace that you go at and
um was there a time when you had to kind
of check your ego at all because the ego
is a dangerous thing it's not even
something we control
you know that ego it can start to
because you see a reflection of yourself
so often in posters and in people's
smiles they're so excited to see
like little things like that can creep
into your soul and build you up
did you ever struggle with it uh i don't
know that i
necessarily struggle with ego but
obviously when you're just trying to get
started and especially back in those
days
it's everybody's in competition with
each other
and there weren't uh as far as
all of the people that were the
newcomers they
they didn't hang out a lot you know
together with each other i mean
everybody's kind of
and they're very secretive they're
keeping their stuff to themselves
because
they don't want to rush almost or
something exactly they don't want
anybody else to know
exactly what it is that they're doing
for their recipe for success wow
and so it gets competitive and i've
always been a competitive guy yeah
you know i like to compete and i like to
win yeah um
so there there comes a point in time
where you have to
realize that hey a little friendly
competition there's nothing wrong with
that but at the same time
you have to remember that
you know nobody was more surprised to
have the career
success than i was i remember in the
early days man
you know you dream about it you dream
about wanting to have that
but it becomes a reality i mean when it
becomes a reality
i remember being on stage man and i'm
you know
you'd be in these big huge arenas that
seated
you know 25 000 people and it's sold out
and they're there to see you and i'm
looking at the band and looking at the
guys and it's going
can you believe this [ __ ] is happening
it is this is
this is unbelievable to me tell me i was
dreaming baby
that's unbelievable yeah wow yeah
yeah there's something sometimes there's
some surprising moments you can never
really
live in the fame or in the popularity
it's almost like it's something that's
bigger than you it's
exactly it's like um you can't really
wear it that much it doesn't feel like i
mean i guess you could if you really
wanted to that would almost seem bizarre
but
um it's almost something that even
though you're sitting in it
you marvel at it almost like you're in a
pond but you have waders on or something
for sure like it's not seeping into you
but you're right there in it
i think it's uh for me
i am no more the extrovert
that i am on stage uh
in real life than you could ever imagine
i mean i'm just i've i've always been
you know i kind of
you know i'm i'm one of those guys that
you know i kind of keep things on the
down low
you know and that sort of thing um
and any partying i did back in those
days i did
pretty much with a very small group yeah
uh
and it was hidden from the public yeah
of course that was before cell phones
and all that other stuff
everybody had cameras everywhere that
that didn't happen back then
but um for me
it was about just um
i don't know maintaining uh
the love for the for the music but being
able to
you know when the when the when the show
is over it's almost like you put on
that's going to sound bad to say but
it's almost like you put on
this this suit that is travis tritt
right on stage of course and then as
soon as you come off stage that suit
comes off and
the real me the real my real personality
comes back
right through well i think it's almost a
necessity because you also
want to be a showman at that point like
there's a level of
it's not really expectation but you want
to give people their money worth you
want to put on your
best absolutely self at those you know
especially at that moment where they
come to see you and you came to see them
it's like watching a college football
game you know
if you watch the team right before they
run on the field
what are they doing they're jumping up
and down they're banging each other in
the head with their helmets
and they're firing each other up to go
out there on this field man
there is nobody on this planet that's
going to do
better at what we're about to do on this
field
today than us and that's exactly the
kind of thing
that i have always had to do in order to
be able to get up enough nerve to go out
on
stage and backstage i would tell myself
i started doing this
as a ritual and i still do it to this
day if i'm backstage
and the lights are going down and
they're getting ready to you know
fire off the band and i'm getting ready
to run out there
i am backstage jumping up and down
and firing myself and i'm telling myself
in my head
there's no other time that i think this
way but at that particular moment
i'm thinking to myself there is nobody
on this earth living or dead
that is going to be able to do a better
job
of entertaining these people than what
i'm about to do
right now i am and i fire myself
up yeah of course as soon as i come off
stage i realize there's a whole
hell yeah you know that a whole lot
better at this than i am
but in order to get you know whatever
you have to know look it's a lot you're
going out there
and the lights are there you have to
meet the the environment it's like you
can't show up to your wedding day like
in a
in in beach clothes you know like you
got to you have to meet the moment
that's exactly right um did your son go
to school here
no um i live in in georgia
still and uh my
oldest daughter and my son my oldest son
are both striving to be artists
in the business and they're working real
hard at it my youngest son
is my middle son excuse me my oldest one
he is his music is very different than
mine my daughter's she's kind of a
throwback to a kind of a linda ron stack
kind of
era yeah and she's wanting to bring that
kind of back
but more in a direct country
um style and my middle son he's more
he's more southern rock blackberry smoke
yeah
kind of into some gun yeah oh yeah man
uh you know so uh but they're both very
talented and
you know it kind of makes you feel good
when your kids
come along and does it want to be a part
of the family business you know
i like that yeah that's kind of cool is
it hard to be supportive since you had
such success because success is a unique
thing it's like
there's people that deserve it that
don't get it and there's you know it's a
real
wheel of fortune out there but is it
tough to be a parent of uh
of artists like you know knowing that
you've had success
not knowing exactly what their future
will be um
is it hard to like balance how you um
how you kind of parent that and support
it or is it easy i'm just
it's scary i mean because you've seen
i've seen so many people in this
industry
that the industry has literally chewed
them up and spit them out yeah and
um it's your chances once again your
chances
of being successful in this industry or
being successful in sports or whatever
are minute they're
minuscule to reach that success level
so um it's it's always a thing but
i i have to tell them because i raised
my kids all three of them
from the time they were born to believe
that
the only limitations that you have on
yourself are the ones that you put on
yourself
you can do anything you can accomplish
anything but
the biggest part of of being successful
i think
is just showing up every day and
constantly try to work to move yourself
forward
constantly try to do something
constantly try to learn something
constantly try to make yourself better
yeah um
so that you and i think when you do that
you appreciate it more when it does
happen
was there moments where you had to trust
your instincts over what other people
were telling you or anything like that
was there moments where
you kind of like just had to follow like
an inner voice or inner vibe
uh where maybe the market or the
you know there's a lot of technicians
that are also in every business you know
was there was there times like that
along your path i started out
uh i came out with that first single
which was country club in 1989
and i'm a member of is that that's it
that's it and it became
a top 10 hit and then we came with the
album
in 1990 and the second single was
helping me hold on third single was i'm
going to be somebody
all all those were huge and then the
fourth single i released this song
called put some drive in your country
that i had written
at uh duane allman's gravesite down in
macon georgia down at rose hill cemetery
years ago damn mushrooms or something
you already know
just that's where they used to hang out
that's because that song
memory of elizabeth reed that was on on
a gravestone that's right down at the
bottom of the cemetery where they used
to go down there and
hang out damn so uh i just used to sit
by
the grave and just try to soak up some
of that vibe that energy
and because that's that song
had all these distorted rock guitars on
it and it
it was a throwback to that leonard
skinner almond brothers kind of thing
man everybody in nashville tennessee
that was involved in the music industry
and everybody at
radio in country radio all of a sudden
they just
came out man claws out
and they started angry oh pissed off
because you had what taken their sound
no because i
was not following the rules
at the time of country music which were
you can use pedal steel guitar and you
can do this and you can do that
but we don't allow that kind of stuff
you know so uh
all these writers in these country music
magazines man they start trashing me and
i turn on the radio and hear some disc
jockey or some program director
talking about oh well he's just trying
to be a rebel or he's
he's a he must be hard to get along with
some of them actually
came out privately and said it he's an
[ __ ] yeah that's kind of cool
i think it's kind of dope dude sometimes
you hear somebody that you're an [ __ ]
it hurts you a little bit but you're
like oh that's kind of cool well it was
starting it was starting to get to me
and then they hit me with the one that
really did
the most damage at the time they said
well he's just an outlaw
damn and it was really starting to
to get to me until i met waylon jennings
we have a question that came in right
here this might be pertaining to it
actually so let's uh just pop this up
and see if it fits in man
hey theo hey travis hey baby hey man
this is josh
southern indiana travis i've seen you in
concert
a couple of times always remember the
tribute to waylon jennings
tell me how he influenced your life and
your singing
thanks man gang gang gang brother and
i'll
and i'll attack on to that question
thank you for the question man and i
love you brother thank you for
submitting that and um
yeah you kind of got accepted by like
the
you got that that dirty thumbs up from
the bad boys in a weird way you know
which was
what was that kind of like you know and
i guess what role did kind of whalen
play in that and um
yeah waylon told me that first time i
met him
he um i was getting ready to leave we
came into the dress we were playing a
show together at the omni in atlanta
and uh and you're younger than him by
how much i i know that by buying
a lot um 20 something years 30 something
here
so do you or is it like when you're
spending time with him is it i mean it's
almost like
it's like a seventh grader being around
the ninth grader and assuming kind he
was a hero
i mean i loved everything about him
before i ever met him i loved his
singing voice i loved his song right now
i loved his guitar picking i loved
everything about him
but one of the things i loved about him
was he was not afraid to do things
his own way and um he sat me down
in his dressing room that first that
first time we ever met and he said
listen i've been
listen hoss i've been hearing all the
stuff that they've been saying about you
in nashville and on these radio stations
he said let me just remind you that
everything that they are saying about
you now is exactly what they said
about me and about willie nelson
and johnny cash and hank williams jr
and david alan coe all
he just goes down the list and he said
let me ask you a question
he said um are you still
selling records and i said yeah i said
man i've been lucky everything i've done
so far
sold platinum or better a million copies
are better and he's
he said well are you still drawing
people into your shows i said yeah man
we're playing
huge arenas and they're sold out he said
listen those are the people you should
care about their opinion
because all these people in nashville
they're saying all this stuff about you
they get their
their music for free he said these
people that come out there he said those
are the people
that work hard 40 50 60 hours a week
to put food on the table for their
families yeah and he said
and they're willing to spend a certain
amount of that
hard-earned money to buy your music
every time you put out new music and
occasionally they'll splurge for a
concert ticket to come see you
when you play in their hometown he said
those are the only people
that matter and as long as you're
pleasing them what you obviously
are to hell with all the rest of these
people yeah and man that was like an
epiphany for me
uh and it also it took a tremendous
amount
of weight off of my shoulders because i
realized at that particular point
waylon and all the rest of those guys
that were labeled as outlaws
they got that label by simply doing the
same thing that i was doing which is
just
wanting to do my music my own way
and do show my influences all my
influences
which were very
widespread i lo i grew up country was
always my
center george jones merle haggard that
was my
center but i also grew up loving the
allman brothers leonard skinner marshall
tucker band
yeah charlie daniels and then of course
the eagles in boston and
and fleetwood mac and you know all this
other stuff
and then blues i was always a blues fan
still am
your voice has a lot of it man when i
listen to some of your tunes i'm like
man this reminds me
there are moments where it goes into a
god like a
light gospel you know what i'm saying or
a light uh
it takes me through like the different
neighborhoods that were
you know adjacent to the neighborhoods i
grew up in it takes me through
there's just uh yeah i can really i can
feel some of that man well mississippi
man i mean that's
so much great blues stuff came out of
there
you know and uh that's one of the
reasons why
that was that was always a staple if you
take if you take bluegrass and if you
take
um uh blues
and straight ahead country and southern
rock
and mix all those together and then
sprinkle a little bit of southern gospel
over the top of it that's the gospel
baby that's me
looking for the lord man that's like
jerry clower he ended up being a pastor
at the end of his time i think
yeah i think so he was a preacher at the
end of his time here's a picture right
here where you go back to that sean
here's a picture of you
and uh and mr jennings right here is it
kind of interesting to see this photo
oh yeah that was the first time we met
really that was right before we had that
conversation
that i just told you about and was he
like uh did he carry himself like an
outlaw car oh
he had that jesse james vibe a little
his givea [ __ ] was totally broken
he didn't care dude that's awesome man
yeah man
to have that moment right there yeah
that was the first night
and did he have any traditions that you
noticed kind of backstage or what was
kind of did he have any i
as far as traditions i don't you know
uh were you allowed to spend time with
him backstage before he kind of liked to
be by himself or did he no he was
he was always really good about you know
anytime i was around he and i
we whalen was one of the kind of people
if he liked you he lets you know it
and uh one of his
favorite sayings that that i remember
was
because a lot of people they would talk
about man when you do this many shows
do you warm up or do you how do you
prepare for a show
and whalen's favorite answer to that
question was
i get up off whatever i'm sitting on and
go out and play music for people that's
what i do
and that answer alone just gives you an
idea of what it is
his his he was just cool man a
cool guy and a guy that was just
you know wanting to do his kind of music
his own way
and that's what what he was going to do
and he didn't give a [ __ ]
what anybody thought about that i love
that you know
sleeping is a popular hobby
and uh and you really you you need to
start
making sure you're doing it not being
able to sleep because of politics or
pandemics
or because of a neighbor who's probably
inbred and
and he's over there trying to holler at
his own sister different things keep you
awake
helix has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete
and matches your body type with your
sleep preferences
because those are two different things
and they will
let you know the perfect mattress
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else
you shouldn't do it with helix you're
getting a mattress you know
will be perfect for the way you sleep
so if you're looking for a mattress take
the quiz
and start goldilockin and get the rest
you need
don't ever go to a mattress store again
helix is offering up to 200 off of all
mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helix
sleep dot com slash theo
now that is what i call a quality deal
that's helix sleep.com
t-h-e-o for up to 200 off
and two free pillows helix sleep.com
theo get the rest you need
you know sometimes your penis ain't good
it ain't good
and that's on you sometimes and
sometimes that's on god and sometimes
that's on society
you know i remember a case of of uh weak
erections passed through our town once
when i was young
and everybody was just barely just
limping out the front they pants
quiet times at night well these days
you can have bluechew bluechew.com
get the first chewables with the active
ingredients sildenafil
or toddleoffle bluechew.com
affiliated physicians work with you to
find the dosage
active ingredients that is best for you
and your penis bro
take care of your penis take care of
that hard thing
no in-person doctor visit no awkward
conversations
bluechew.com they're made in the usa
here's a great deal for you
support the podcast get that rection
visit bluechew.com get your first order
free
when you use promo code t-h-e-o
just pay five-dollar shipping that's b l
u e c
h e w dot com promo code
theo get hard in the penis boy
do you um do you see any of that
nowadays still like there's a lot of
and i don't want to judge it there's a
lot of cookie cutter stuff out there but
um you know i come from a cloth where i
didn't have much luck with the
entertainment industry so i started
creating my own stuff and
right you know went on joe rogan and
learned oh i can podcast and talk about
my life
sure i spent a lot of time in hollywood
trying to like um
get rid of whatever kind of accent i had
in my throat even though i didn't grow
up like really redneck we just grew up
kind of poor and white
right more like white trash like we
didn't have a boat right you know what
i'm saying like i didn't have bait
you know what i'm saying like those were
[ __ ] you know chicken liver was a
delicacy i thought
you know so i thought it was sushi when
i first heard about it you know
[ __ ] it seemed pretty nice but but so
we didn't have like a country kind of
vibe we just had more of like a regular
white vibe
but when i got to hollywood they it
really was like oh here's a country it
was like there was no nuance to anything
right and i for years i would take vocal
classes trying to like get like a
straight normal voice where i sounded
exactly
and then finally one day i just said man
i just can't even
i'm just tired of pretending you know i
just don't even know what's going on
anymore sometimes and once i started to
fall into my own world
you know in my own life is when i
started to have a little bit more
success
do you see any outlaws still out there
these days do you see any
there's a few i mean uh in just the last
few years you know you've had
people that have basically chosen to
um say to hell with whatever's going
on in nashville and they really don't
use that as as a gauge
for what they think they should be doing
right and they're not
they're not afraid to break those rules
you know you've got guys like uh cody
jenks you know and some of those guys
jason is bill's one
uh some of those other guys that are
they just want to do their kind of music
their own way
yeah and um those are the people that i
think
uh especially in today's world they
stand out
from the crowd you know and that's all i
was trying to do back in those days to
not only just show my influences but
also
be a little bit something different so
that people remember your name and
remember your music and they remember
your your
performances because they're a little
bit different than everybody else
you need to get people to remember you i
remember thinking
man i you know i don't care if they
remember my jokes
right i want people to come back to see
me exactly as a human as a
as an entertainer but also as so i need
to get as close to my work as a
as i can to my humanity yes so that when
they see
one they see a little bit of the other
and i want them to come back and pay a
fair price ticket to see me as a person
i want them to be like oh we're going to
see theo like
what jokes does he tell i don't even
know that's fine if i don't
they don't even know what jokes i tell i
just want them to come and see me don't
you think a lot of that comes from
people just want to
want to gravitate towards something
that's real
i think i think especially these days
yeah you know we saw on this podcast you
know we do a lot of
episodes where it's just me talking and
to nobody really but
um and so yeah we try to talk about like
just things that make us feel or that
make us think or
yeah you because everybody has these
things going on and it's like we've kind
of disappeared
some of that's kind of disappeared it's
everything's become so formulaic
it has it has and that's one of the
things that
you know is when you when i hear people
talk about
being a little bit nostalgic for the the
music that
took place and not just the music but
lifestyle with all the yeah
all the stuff that's gone on in the last
few years
um i'm just in the in the process right
now of releasing a single off of a new
album
and it's called smoking a bar and it's
talking about
kind of being nostalgic for the days
when
we didn't seem to have all this upheaval
and you know
people came by neighbors came by and
talked on the porch
we all said good night we never locked
the front doors yeah even downtown you
could still see the stars
when the world turned slower and you
could smoke in a bar
oh yeah you know that kind of thing so
and i forgot about that
there yeah i mean and people are
nostalgic for that kind of thing
especially as crazy as things
are getting um those of us that are
that are old enough to remember a
simpler time
i think we kind of long for that do you
feel like well and
well it's one of the reasons why
recently i've tried to relocate to
nashville i still have my place in los
angeles and i'm from louisiana
originally but um
but i do notice here there is a there is
certainly a bit more of you have a
little more time for people
as humans right um and it is a bit of a
slower pace
there's a little more trust amongst
people there it is it's not as eroded
away
it hasn't been as marketed right um
you know i uh dude i remember i used to
play these have this place in st
louis the funny bone over there so it
was a comedy club man and the first
the first show was no smoking right this
the late two shows dude those [ __ ]
were smoking bro i remember bro
like dog i didn't know if there was nine
people in there
or [ __ ] nine thousand there was so
much smoke it was
seven foot ceilings trust me and no uh
no uh i don't even think they had a damn
system to get the smoke out they had a
frickin i swear to god
they had a waitress by the window with
the window open just waving a menu at it
like
they didn't have a damn game plan bro
and i couldn't tell you bro if it was
i saw a damn boat go through the mist i
didn't know what was going on
i said it is [ __ ] thick in here
but i would just still do my shows i had
cancer by that second show but i kept
doing them boy
i was in remission by the second day i
was there i was in remission
did you ever smoke cigarettes oh yeah i
used to smoke a man i smoked for
probably about 16 years yeah
i did about the same thing do you miss
smoking it sometimes i miss some of it
not at all
how bad did it get for you um i never
was a heavy smoker i
at my i would always smoke when i drank
and so at the very most i was maybe a
pack a week
that's not bad you know so it wasn't bad
at all but um
i got bronchitis in um i think it was
1992
and i went to the doctor and he said man
he said i don't give a [ __ ] if you start
back
immediately but you've got to quit
smoking for at least three weeks
and i thought to myself well if i can
quit for three weeks man i can quit
completely
you know and then uh ever since then i'm
not completely tobacco-free i still dip
every now and then you know yeah i
couldn't dip good man
yeah well the good thing about dipping
is nobody's ever died from second-hand
spit yeah
[Laughter]
well i don't know i mean who knows
what's going on in some places who knows
what's going on some people caught up in
some wild [ __ ]
but uh dude i remember when i was young
we went
the first time we got a can of dip man
it was like cherry skull or something
yeah
and my buddy had got his driver's permit
in louisiana they gave it to you at 15.
man they gave you that bastard at 15.
and it didn't even have a picture of you
literally had a drawing of you on it i
was like damn that [ __ ] looks
sketchy as hell and uh
my buddy got his mom's car and we got a
can of cherry skull dude and that was
our night bro
we was just hitting puberty man so we
didn't even know nothing about really
women we knew about them but we weren't
thinking about it right
exactly so we went out man and i got
sick on it right
and i puked out of my buddy's driver's
side window then i got so sick i said i
need to sit in the back
i puked out of each window in the back
okay look
so in the morning my buddy his mom came
back in town or whatever
she sees the car and there's vomit out
of it all three windows
so she said who you went out with some
kind of party he said
look i went out with theo he got sick he
just vomited out of all three windows
his mom to this day doesn't believe him
she said what kind of maniac would vomit
out of three different windows
that'll make you do it it was fun
especially the first time oh yeah
dude i missed stuff like that you
remember the first time uh
remember the first time you ever drank
or anything like that or anything yeah
man man i shouldn't even tell this story
but i'm gonna tell you
yeah i was uh i was
16 years old and my high school
was doing uh uh the play god spell
and i was i was in you're in the play
i was singing oh damn damn on stage i
was singing off stage oh damn yeah if
they went ready for you in the center no
no no no
put them in the wings there you go yeah
and uh
the guy that was our theater teacher
he said we were doing rehearsals and
he's sipping on a coke can and
i just got a whiff of it and it smelled
like
peppermint and i thought now that's not
coca-cola man so i asked him one day i
said what are you drinking
and he said uh peppermint snobs
and he told you and he gave me something
oh hell yeah
so the lord working man i remember
that was all i needed right there man
and it's like
yeah this is good and uh until i got
sick on it then i can't
i can't stand the smell of it to this
day oh i could imagine that's a strong
one
yeah that's a weird one but oh god i
just
i didn't sing with you just do it at the
shows uh
yeah well i mean all my buddies i mean
we're
we're country boys no you lived out in
the country so
you know the thing everybody went to
work did what they had to do
and then when you get off work let's go
buy some beers and let's go find some
place to hang and party
oh yeah you know and that might be a
club
that might be a bonfire out back yeah
that might be
you know there was a big waterfall uh
that was close to our our area where the
chattahoochee river ran
through and a lot of times hey we're all
going to meet at the falls tonight let's
go over there
you know so just you know stuff like
that yeah it was
you know normal normal yeah and such a
good
such a rich environment for creating
music i feel like
such a rich environment for creating um
memories and moments like i don't like
i just remember yeah things then a lot
of songs and i felt like had a little
bit
and i hate to blanket statement like
this because it's it's not always true
but there was sometimes more
story that i could relate to
um maybe i was also at an age where i
was really just growing up and still
coming into life you know when you're
in your late teens and twenties um
but yeah there's something about like
moments that are just yours where you
can really then
create art from them whereas now so many
moments are
uh they're so manipulated before
they you ever even put the pen to the
paper that's right because they've been
shared so many times or
back in those days man i mean and and
from its
its inception country music has always
been
in my opinion the
best genre for storytelling
of all music no matter where you're from
what your background is there's gonna be
a country music song out there
back in those days there were that is
going to
speak to how you're feeling no matter
how you feel about your
your job your social status your
family your country um
your uh spouse your
boyfriend girlfriend whatever um
there's going to be a song that's going
to relate
to how you're feeling and the things
that you're dealing with in your life at
that particular point
and that's one of the things i i think i
miss
the most about a lot of today's country
music because
i just miss those great stories man yeah
being able to tell those great stories
that
everybody can relate to johnny's daddy
exactly exactly dude by the time they
got to the end and they're in the damn
hospital i'm just talking
i'm at the gym bro and i'm [ __ ]
crying
i'm looking trying to do 45's and i'm
[ __ ] see that's good
that's good because that means it
obviously
touched a really special spot
in you that made you feel if it makes
you
feel something yeah i don't care what it
is
anger fear of sadness
joy whatever it may be if it makes you
feel something
yeah that's a pretty darn good sign man
yeah man i remember i'm trying to think
of ones well we went to the dances so a
lot of y'alls music they would play at
some of our dances once i got like later
in the high school man
and some of those man you hit those
ballads you get out there with a lady
bro there was nothing
like that there was nothing like that
man and that's where music becomes more
than just music for a lot of people too
it becomes
really kind of the soundtrack of your
life yeah that's one of the things about
music that's always amazed me it's like
i can remember
where i was for very specific moments in
my life
and exactly what song was playing in the
background like
first time i ever drove my dad's car by
myself you know
or first time i ever went on a date
first time i ever kissed a girl first
time i
you know all these different things and
i knew exactly what
song was playing in the background
for each one of those individual things
but
because they're they're not just
something that's playing in the
background it's the soundtrack of your
life
and every time i hear that song today
yeah any one of those songs
it takes me right back to that spot
again and i think a lot of people
music does that for them yeah i think
man my mom
my mom got one of those uh warner
brothers like music disc things for like
19 cents she got like six albums you
know
so she picked out four and she let us
pick out two you know
and um and we would have to clean the
house to brian adams every weekend man
absolutely yeah yeah man have i told
yeah no that's not even brianna
no that's uh uh rod stewart rod stewart
rod stewart was one of the secrets you
got leonard cohen rod stewart brian
adams
but man we would uh oh and the traveling
wheelbarrow oh yeah
dude that was a band that never got the
i mean i'm sure they maybe did at the
time but i mean that was even
before your time but it was like man
that band well that was like the
um that was like the country music
equivalent of what the highway men were
which was johnny cash willie nelson
waylon jennings
and chris christopherson i got to go
back and listen to more of that yeah
it's good stuff man
yeah the traveling will berries man yeah
that was some treasure
that's some of the best in the business
right there
you got tom petty in there you got
george harrison
did you ever want to did you ever try to
cheat genres a little do you ever feel
like you were
trying to get out of your own like
because it's like i know it's
not cheat genres but did you ever
was there ever a moment where you felt
like you were just sometimes your our
lives change
right and so the art we're putting out
changes with it and it's sometimes it's
hard to
you know we're like man this is this has
worked so well for me i'm almost scared
of
getting older growing into something
different or anything did you ever feel
like there were moments where your music
changed
no i really did not i've always kind of
used the same recipe
for making records and that is that i
just want to
include a little bit of each one of
those different genres
that were so influential to me so
there's going to be uh
in the process of just recording this i
just recorded the first
album that i've done in studio
in 13 years oh dang and i recorded it
with dave cobb who produces
yeah the legend chris stapleton and
sturgill simpson
and all those guys and it's done now
yeah it's done and how do
you feel good about it i feel great
about it it's going to be out may 7th
it's called set in stone but
people were asking me when people found
out that i was going to be doing an
album
a new album uh what's it going to be
like man are you going straight
head country are you going more toward
the rock side or are you going to do
more blues or what are you doing i said
man
the only way i know how to answer that
it's going to be a travis tread album
and that means that every travis street
album that i've ever done
has had the same recipe which is show a
little bit of the blues show a little
bit of the
southern rock rock influence show a
little bit of that straight ahead
country stuff show a little bit of the
bluegrass
and just show and sprinkle a little bit
of southern gospel over the top of it
and that's me so that's exactly what we
did and there's
um if you uh
are particularly into one genre over
another
uh you may not like every song but
there's gonna be something on there
you're gonna like
i like that we got a question right here
from a fellow that came in let's get to
this right here
thanks sean
what's up theo hey mr travis trick one
of my favorite artists by the way me and
my dad
just went to a show two years ago and uh
it was a blast
uh you guys got some fine looking
mullets trying to growing out myself
for travis i'm just curious some of your
new favorite artists country it's the
same as it used to be but
i just wanted your take thanks guys gang
gang
well you said cody jenks you said um
i love chris stapleton too i think he's
he's uh
he's tremendously talented uh
yeah he's thomas it's almost like
listening to a cavern of
nostalgia comfort there's a lot that
goes in he's it's almost like a whiskey
or something he's like a really
good whiskey exactly he's really good i
love marcus king
oh yeah he was just on uh tom segura's
podcast wasn't he sean
yeah people love him he's such a neat
person as well it seems like
yeah man he's he is a talented dude
there he is yeah he's so uh there's just
something immediately so endearing about
him when you even see him
he's got a great voice great guitar
player
great musician he's uh
and he's got a lot of that same blues
southern rock influence and he's not
afraid to show it
that larry fleet you listen to it oh i
love larry fleet yeah i actually met
larry fleet
for the first time i would i was hosting
uh
a show for a usa network called real
country
uh back about uh i might remember that
three years ago
yeah uh me shania twain jake owen
were the were they oh jake's awesome
guys host judges
and uh one of the people that came up in
the competition
was larry fleet and i remember telling
him
um as soon as he actually won his round
and i remember going up to him
after cameras were shut off and just
telling him
man you are an amazing talent i'm
looking forward to hearing more from you
and he just has just done some great
stuff recently
he's got a song out called that's where
i find god oh yeah
that is just oh it's one of the ones
that made me feel when you talked about
songs that make you feel
there you go i mean it's like uh
it's like somebody took a trailer hitch
from
the world and literally hooked it onto
my heart
that's right i know right so there's
something especially does there
um yeah he's a super unique man super
talent
um i i believe that we're kind of
getting into a time where
uh morgan wally listen to morgan yeah
like morgan yeah i love morgan
yeah he came on he came on it like maybe
a month ago yeah um
yeah he's a close buddy of mine man he's
got he's he's almost
too talented yeah exactly i almost feel
like sometimes
i listen to so many of his songs i'm
like jesus christ man throw a couple bad
ones in here
you know and then he's got like he's
always like you know he's like
look guys i almost want to tell you you
know they don't
somebody just leaked my music at walmart
and i don't know
i don't even shop at walmart i love him
bro he's such a uh
and morgan you know i love you so i'm
just uh but i introduced him to ufc we
watched some ufc fights a couple weeks
ago
um he's a special talent man he's a
special talent
um i think that people are getting more
into
i think like you're talking nostalgia
and connection
i feel like during this virus during the
pandemic that a lot of people have
started to say
i don't know if i want this rat race
whatever this
is it doesn't the allure of it it's
almost like the curtain got pulled back
on some of just the
relentless go go for what yeah exactly
and i think a lot of us well i know for
myself i can only speak for i'm sitting
and
kind of just in myself and saying what
do i want
i want to feel good right you know i
want other people around me to feel good
i want to be able to
be a part of things that are good
exactly and i think that a lot of people
are starting to feel that way
i think there's going to be a a
resurgence of
not country music but music that
connects people
music that makes people feel i'm i'm
looking forward to seeing
what takes place in in all of music
really
but especially in country music i'm
looking forward to seeing what takes
place
as a result of being locked down for
all these many months and and
because you know good and well all these
great songwriters and
all these artists and all these people
they have had nothing better to do with
their time than to sit down and do
exactly that all of those things
and i think it's going to be it's almost
going to be like a baby boom
except for music i think i think we're
going to see that and that's exciting
to think about but the baby's a peddled
steel maybe that's a pregnant yeah
it's a six pound eight ounce petal steel
guitar it's a girl
congratulations it's a progressive
instrument
we have a question that came in right
here from you might even notice this
lady she was at uh
i remember her from she was at kid
rock's 50th actually
awesome hey travis tammy here
big fan i think you had some of the best
music videos
of the 90s i think your performance in
your video tell me i was dreaming
should have won an oscar my question to
you is
i know you've done a lot of acting in
your career which do you prefer
full-time rock star or full-time movie
star
love you i love you too that's a good
question man because at certain points
of
of popularity they start to offer you
things that they might not have offered
you you don't have to go into that room
to audition as much
that's exactly man i had no aspirations
whatsoever about being an actor
right but did it grow on you though well
i enjoyed it and i'll tell you the
reason why
um i was always
out of my element when i was doing a
movie or a television show or whatever
it may be when i was doing
any kind of acting and
so because i was so insecure about it
and so nervous about it
i didn't just go in and learn my lines i
learned the whole damn script
i knew everybody's lying and um
because i'm i have a real hard time
multitasking
i get real laser focused on whatever it
is i'm doing at the moment
so if i'm songwriting i'm focused on
that if i'm recording i'm
really focused on that and if i'm
performing i'm really
focused on that so doing
these acting roles it forced me to
concentrate
so much on that that i completely
took a vacation from music i didn't
think about music i didn't
talk about music i didn't try to write
music or whatever
and i found that the benefit of that was
when i finished
a acting role and came back to the music
i found that i was more creative um
it was like man this is a fresh start
again
yeah and um i wrote better songs
um i performed better my mind was more
in the game
because if you do anything i think over
a long period of time same thing over
and over again
it can tend to get a little bit
monotonous yeah but
if you get a break from it and then you
get a chance to come back and look at it
through a little bit different
perspective
uh it helped me tremendously i think it
helps make me a better artist and
and a better songwriter and a better
entertainer
was there um was there a role ever that
you kind of like
oh this is kind of neat like because
acting one of the reasons that people
don't know acting if you're a touring
artist
acting takes a lot of time it's a really
long so
you know as a musician you could
probably do six shows in a daytime of
you would do one set or one scene or
half an episode of a tv program or
something so
that's one of the reasons i think a lot
of uh entertainers don't go over into
acting that aren't actors
right um was there a role or something
you felt like you kind of got into or
something man
the one i had the most fun with was
i got to do do you remember a show
called tales from the crypt
yes i remember the beginning the opening
thing
yeah exactly okay i got to do
tales from the crypt with hank azaria
and with um ben stein
and i played we were robbing
um bodies for this
doctor so that he could try to find what
he believed was
the soul gland in a person
and at the end i'll
go ahead and give you a spoiler away
yeah there you go right there
i get my head cut off
and i come back from the dead am
because they didn't remove my soul gland
i come back from the dead
and that was so
much fun because there were no
limitations on what the director
basically said do whatever you want to
do come up with your own voice for it
act as crazy as you possibly can
do any wild stuff that you want to do
and this
your your parameters are just
wide open and that was
so much fun man i came up you know i
come out and of course i'm
i've got this head on backwards and i'm
i look like i'm working
your head yeah they did a they did a
todd masters who did all of the special
effects for that
show he created a head a rubber head of
me
it was perfect that they dropped down a
well and i come back out of the well
and man it was that was just so
much fun to do that particular role
because they were
you know it's always fun to play kind of
the bad guy yeah
you know that's always fun but but
especially when it's like you're this
monster that has
returned from the dead there's no
there's no limitations on that oh yeah
huh it's free free but it's all it's
it's open game yeah exactly yeah you're
already dead dude it's a wrap
i do whatever you want now dude i missed
the old days man that couldn't have had
peeping toms and [ __ ] when i was growing
up dude we used to do peeping tom and
when i was growing up dude
we had a guy in our neighborhood who had
a ladder and we'd have to like almost
sign it out for him because everybody
was always borrowing it
oh we get that [ __ ] on a thursday dude
we get out there dude
do some peeping time i don't even have
that anymore
you know what i'm saying like damn it
was the last time you heard of anybody
getting arrested for peeping time
dude in high school we had a buddy who
did but yeah and everybody
all my other friends like man that's
disgraceful i'm like i think it's pretty
cool
i told him i even said hey man don't
smoke cigarettes out there and leave the
butts that's how they catch it yeah you
got it
and i said look if you can be out there
for a couple hours do a little gardening
while you're out there
there you go have some respect there you
go you're looking at yeah
have some respect dude i miss those days
man
i just you know i'm heavily nostalgic i
love nostalgia i love like just
sometimes just laying back and trying to
feel through the moments that i had as a
child
and as a young adult and there's just
something so wonderful about like the
freshness of life then how it's
the every moment is like in a ziploc bag
and you're just cracking that thing open
for the first time
you know um was there what about like a
first kiss was there anything special
that you had like that growing up
oh yeah i mean well yeah
falling in love oh it was fun oh
man it was awesome it was awesome i
thought it was fun
it was so severe oh yeah exactly
exactly and everything everything that
happened man
you could relate it to oh man this
relates to how i feel about so you know
it's it's just crazy but
you know the i don't think that ever
really goes away completely
you know because i remember when i met
my wife
um i've been married three times this is
my third marriage like getting hit by
rice huh yeah
our bird seed yeah yeah man that cheap
rice
that's right my wife and i we met in 95
and we got married in 97 and we've been
together ever since
and i've heard a lot of nice things
about we were at hillary williams
birthday last night and she said oh
she had a ton of nice things she's
talking about you guys she's just
wonderful but
i knew as soon as i met her that this
person
is it wasn't love at first sight but it
was darn sure
heavy attraction at the first sight man
because she
not only was she beautiful but she was
just so down to earth and relatable and
that's that's the kind of people i grew
up around
so we just kind of gravitated toward
each other and it just
and i i remember that how that felt and
even though it was you know 20 some odd
years ago
it's it doesn't feel like that to me it
feels like
it was you know could have been last
week
i think some of that is adult love
whenever you kind of get that person
that you're just so comfortable being
around
um but yeah i remember childhood love it
was just like i remember i'd go to
school and i knew i was going to see
this girl katie and like
all day i was like just practicing what
face i would have on when she looked
over
you know and it was always the worst one
when she finally looked
it was always a [ __ ] worse one um
do you remember a first kiss there was
some even just a little like smooch
around the neighborhood anything yeah
uh no offense to your wife she's the
best oh yeah
yeah well she doesn't mind that because
she knows
uh i first girl i ever kissed was a girl
by the name of uh
melody mccoy and uh i was dating her
and she was in that same play godspell
so this was all
around the same time oh yeah you
liquored up you're learning it all
absolutely i'm learning quick
i want to hopefully the same guy that
gave you the liquor didn't teach you how
to run the smooch man that's what i'm
hoping
and i had a my first car what was it
a 1969 rambler
three on the tree 306 cylinder
damn new oh no 69
oh ramble oh my bad 69 rambler it was oh
it was a piece of junk man yeah
yeah if rambler was an appropriate name
for it oh my god it was terrible
but it was mine and i bought it yeah how
much was it
uh 500 bucks hell yeah dude had a 1984
ford escort for six hundred dollars
somebody stole the passenger seat out of
it
so people would get in and that'd go
directly to the back nobody would have
wanted the passenger seat out of this
one man it was
awful it was terrible it was so bad
instead of you know how you turn on the
windshield washers
and spray the windshield washer fluid up
yeah well this one had a little bulb
on the floorboard that you had to pump
like a like a water
a water gun
it was terrible like hold on there's
some bird [ __ ] out there
exactly exactly but man that yeah we
went out
uh where'd you take her do you remember
i took her to a
there's a there was a park close to our
house and they had like
swing sets and you know
one of those merry-go-round things and
i took her to that were you nervous you
remember yeah i was nervous
yeah yeah big time but man oh
that was a great experience dude i
remember they had this girl in my
neighborhood named chrissy hunt and
she was missing a tooth or one of us was
i don't know you know i'm saying it was
that age
i don't know somebody dude between
between two of us i think we had about
11 teeth you know and it was just
i didn't come from a heavily enameled
area you know
and uh and she was
yeah i remember she we kind of locked
ourselves in a room or something i think
we felt so much pressure kids in the
neighborhood were always gonna kiss each
other you know just like
yeah and we were so scared and and then
i remember at one point thinking i was
supposed to like touch her breasts but i
remember touching my own i was so scared
to touch hers i started touching my own
[Music]
i didn't know what to do man i just but
i didn't want to be a
wimp you know yes absolutely dude i
think i had bigger chests than she did
at the time i mean it was just
young you know and we had we had this
guy in our neighborhood the dad was a
elvis impersonator right
but we only had about 600 people in town
we didn't we don't need a [ __ ] elvis
impersonator let's do his alcoholic
oh okay so but i mean he also dressed up
like elvis at least you know so it's
pretty entertaining but
he would make his kids stay in the yard
and he had an electric fence dude and
one of the girls would let me go over
there and like kind of smooch her
through the electricity bro
oh man bro the stress at just god i can
still feel the stress in my neck trying
to kiss through those walls holy cow
god wow man dude and then we had i
forgot about this
so this girl chrissy's brother he was
like i think he more preferred the
company of men you know and so he made
us
i remember this now he made us dress up
like army people
and put our hair back and like she made
her hair look short
hers in her and made me and his sister
kiss each other
dressed up like little men yeah i think
how old
dude i think we're probably about 13 boy
12 maybe
he shouldn't have been doing that he was
only about 16 so i don't think he really
knew what he was doing either but
when i look back on it i'm like why are
we why are we both lieutenants
and then he went into the military years
later he went in did he really yeah he
did man
awesome but uh damn yeah i just
there's something i love about that we
got a question right here that came up
from somebody
what up theo gang baby i just got a
question for travis real quick i want to
know what do you miss most about
the climb to fame in the music industry
when you're out there cutting your teeth
on broadway or wherever you were
what you missed most about that and uh
theo why don't you use some of that
money from your butt and get your tire
fixed
hey man dude i just i had a flat tire
and i
got up to eight cans of fix-a-flat in it
before i finally
took it in man so that's who i am
procrastinator oh i was like you can
hold one more cane
they had to replace a lot of stuff when
i finally got it
they said your tire has plaque buildup i
said plaque build up
take it to the dentist yeah dude i need
to take this somewhere else somewhere
else
um yeah what about that climate because
there's something once you kind of
achieve the left
once you and i mean your level of of of
success is a really rare level but
what do you what do you miss about that
climb what do you miss about like really
miss about some of the early moments you
know i wouldn't say i miss it
but um because you can never replicate
that exactly you can't rip
i mean you can only you know you can
only launch that rocket one time
you know but and when it's all new to
you
you know that you're only you're only a
virgin once yeah
and the fact that um
i was playing all those bars and clubs
and stuff and i've i've told my
my son and my daughter that want to get
into music
about that uh experience
man i learned so much the hard way
playing all those smoky clubs like
you're talking about those smoky bars
and dives and
beer joints and honky tonks and bowling
alleys and pool halls and bowling houses
is always the weirdest
oh man weird place man right you're
hitting a low note and somebody just
gets a split
but you're having to compete against all
of that and plus you're having to
compete against alcohol
to try to get these people's attention
and every one of the places that i
played man they had
they either had pool tables or they had
dart boards or they had
uh pinball machines or maybe all of the
above so you're trying to compete
against all that
and it it was difficult man it was rough
and i went through a lot of nights where
how in the world am i going to get these
people's attention
but uh even though i hated
some of those instances that i was put
in some of those positions i was put in
i wouldn't take anything for him now
because i learned
i learned how if the show
is interrupted for whatever reason if
you break a guitar string for example or
if a mic quits working or something
you learn how to keep people's attention
you learn how to keep the patter up
you learn how to uh
work your way through it and those are
the things that
i still pull from the that
book of knowledge i still pull from that
every single day and i get on stage
so was there a song that you would go to
because it's funny you say that because
i remember being
in places where the the the music was
secondary to the liquor
so it's like these people are having a
good time we're gonna also let you do
comedy over here
right but if you have you want to get
every attention that's gonna you have to
do that there's nobody in here that's
going to help you do that
you know was there a song or something
you went to sometimes when you realized
okay i got to kind of reel it back in
here ever when you were starting yeah
there were there were two there were two
songs that i really learned right off
the bat um
after playing clubs because i started
out with just an acoustic guitar
that was it and then um
i went out in probably i don't know
it was probably 1985
yeah and i went out and bought a fender
twin
amp and i bought a fender stratocaster
and somehow no i've never even
seen one since then but i bought a
hundred foot guitar chord
the first the first two songs my first
two sets rather
that night you know because they're
serving food in there too it's a bar
restaurant kind of thing the first two
sets man i'm up there with my acoustic
guitar and i'm playing james taylor and
john denver and
you know whatever george strait but by
the time it got to that third one
pull out that electric guitar and that
100 foot guitar cord and i'm running out
on top of people's tables
kicking beer and [ __ ] over you know and
just but i i have their attention
coming up absolutely man absolutely and
i'm doing
uh johnny be good yeah you know and
stuff like that
traveling getting people's attention on
the other side of that coin
i found out that because you'd have
fights that would break out you know
yeah would you play a ballad then what
do you do at that point man
i found out they're not only a ballad
but the right ballad
nobody can fight i i learned this
right off the bat man nobody can fight
if you play silent
night the christmas song
[Music]
that will stop a fight quicker than
anything on this planet
yeah man so i learned those two things
right off the bat i learned how to take
them up
and i learned how to take them down if
it got a little bit man
crazy dude i'm so bad at karaoke my song
that i've always done is rocking around
the christmas tree right i do that at
karaoke no matter what time of year it
is
and if people like at first you're like
this guy's [ __ ] new to you
but then about it's only a two minute 16
second song
the one i do right so about a minute and
you kind of see people are kind of okay
with
it and then you're done so you kind of
got it out of your system but i can
relate to going to a christmas carol man
yeah man
using it when you need it it worked um
what's it like to be a father man what's
that what's that experience been like
for you
man it's the greatest thing in the world
i did you know it would be going into it
did you have skepticism about because i
have a lot of fear going about going in
and being a father you're not a father
yet i uh
no i really didn't because and i guess
the reason that i didn't was because
after my second uh divorce
i basically took about six eight years
and man i i played the field i sewed all
the wild oats
that i could have out there huh big time
okay and played the field and the good
thing about it was i
figured out during that period of time
okay this is what i do want and that
right there is what i
definitely don't want and i
so by the time that i met my wife uh
i knew exactly what i was looking for
and i knew she was it
and so having kids with somebody like
that that you feel that way about
it's not scary at all or at least it
wasn't for me it now it would have been
extremely terrifying had it happened in
the first two marriages but
we thank gosh yeah got through both of
those with no kids
but uh i remember being excited to be a
father
um and and
my my daughter when she was born
i uh i was with a
warner brother's records at the time and
i had been with them since the beginning
of my career
and i was looking to
get off of that label and i also wanted
to stay home and see what being a dad
was all about
so as soon as we found out she was on
her way
i told my record label
i'm not doing any more records for you
i'm going to get out of this contract
and i'm staying home i'm not touring i'm
not doing anything
i wanted to be home the first time i
wanted to be home point
obviously when she was born but i wanted
to be home when uh
she took her first steps yeah when she
said her first words
i wanted to be home for all that so i
took from 1998
to 2000 off just to be home and
see what this daddy thing is all about
yeah and was it pretty special oh
extremely this is her right here
extremely
yeah oh you got a beautiful little
family dude oh thank you brother that's
all three your children
yes oh dang huh yeah that's them
a couple shorties in there beautiful
ladies bro sorry
oh wow um what's your daughter's what
was the first daughter's name
tyler reese tyler's and is she the one
that plays music you says yeah
yeah yeah she's been uh obviously before
coveted and everything hit she's been
out on the road doing a lot of shows
uh do you guys play together ever yeah
we do as a matter of fact i took her in
the studio when she was 14
and uh recorded a song for one of my
albums and we
we've been doing that song together i'd
bring her out on the road with me and
you know we'd do that song together and
then she started working on her own
and she's doing shows on her own
and she was really i mean everything was
really
at that stage where it was she was
getting to be known by a lot of people
and then covet hit yeah but it's going
to come back it's going to come right
it's going to come right back
what's something special about tyler
just how even though even just as a
human it doesn't have to be about music
the fact that she is she's got one of
the kindest hearts i think i've ever
ever been around she really is i mean
she can be
now she can be rough yeah you know yeah
she lost her cell phone back
um at easter of last year oh that'll
rough on a girl that's a that's
that's the females vietnam right there
though man she lost her cell phone for
about four or five hours
six hours and man
she didn't speak to me for like a week
you know because i was just trying to
help and oh yeah
it was pissing her off but she's
outside of outside of of the stuff like
that
she's really one of the kindest hearted
people she cares about people
she cares about family and she uh
she's extremely sweet that's cool man
that's cool and uh and your son his name
is taylor you said
no tristan is my middle and then my
youngest one is
tyrion t-a-r-i-a-n oh dang like the
lannisters almost like
game of thrones yeah that's right dope
dude yeah that's dope
um and what's tristan like tristan is uh
he's very laid back he's uh
he looks almost exactly like me um
oh he's got to get that mull going then
does he have that haircut or no yeah
he has some flow yeah praise god he's
got some fun going
yeah the kids call it lettuce you know
that
that's what they call it they call it
that cabbage that's what they call it
cabbage yeah they call it that lettuce
yeah well tristan tritt
is he's coming into his own uh
and the more i watch him perform live
he's got a group called tristan tritt
and pale moon creek
and the more i see him
[Music]
live on stage the more
he looks exactly i look at him and it's
like looking in the mirror wow it's
interesting yeah i said i see him
and i see me it's just a fact but
uh yeah that's him there you go there he
is on the left oh cool
yeah that's him that's cool man
that's neat to have your family kind of
be involved in what you're in and it
seems like you guys are able to navigate
it pretty comfortably without any uh
too much envy or anything like that
that's the thing i would i think would
be tough maybe it would seem like from
an outsider's perspective
if there's like envy from the kids that
makes the parenting uncomfortable or
something yeah everybody
you know our family really has always
gotten along extremely well
and i know one of the things that blows
my mind
as i said my daughter is 23 my son is 21
and my youngest son is 17. and i know
when i was at any one of those ages
man all i wanted to do was get as far
away from my parents
as i possibly could yeah i just get out
on my own
and do my thing but
our kids and i give my wife credit for
this
she raised them with so much of a
an appreciation for the family unit
and hey this is family blood's thicker
than water
you take care of your family amen and
so she instilled that in them and they
still
man i mean they love being with us and
we have some of the greatest times in
the world together just that's cool
going out and doing things and you know
but even like mundane things if
if my wife and i are home uh
watching a movie or something on
television kids come walking through the
room and go
hey what are you watching and listen
watch it with you sit down and watch it
with us
you know that's very cool it's never
happened i know
i know i i would have never done that
yeah
what's something you guys are watching
today anything you and the wife sit back
and watch or a program that you kind of
enjoy
oh man we've been uh gosh we've been
watching so much stuff man
i just watched the center that's what
i'm on season one the center yeah
i haven't seen it it's like a murder
mystery kind of with jessica bill it's
good
oh really yeah we've been watching just
i think we've watched everything that
there is available on
netflix yeah because the covered
lockdown stuff you know
everybody's just staying at home it's
going away pretty quick though do you
start to feel that a little bit
yeah we're starting to see our schedule
starting to open back up
for the next few months and it can't
happen too soon for me
man because there is something about
from from an artist's standpoint i can
tell you that
if you love it as much as i do there is
a part of your life that is not complete
if you're not able to go out there and
do that
at some point interesting um and
i think from an audience standpoint
we have to bring live music back yeah
people are ready chomping at the bit man
i've i've been lucky uh luckier than a
lot of people
i've had the opportunity to do a few
shows here and there in different places
but the people are just so hungry for it
because they've been locked up and
cooped up too
and there's as you well know think about
concerts and stuff that you went to
when you were young and as you grew up
and just the experiences that you had at
some of those places
there is nothing like being in a
in a live audience yeah and your
favorite band or one of your favorite
band doing some of your favorite songs
and you've got your fist up in the air
you're playing air guitar
out in the audience and the lights are
going and
and everybody drinks your buddy exactly
the whole thing man
there is something about that that can't
be replaced by anything else
tell me how is that your song tell me i
was dreaming damn bruh
yeah that's cool is there moments where
you like get so far along where some of
you like holy [ __ ]
i forgot about this we haven't played
this one in a while this one's great
yeah that's got to be pretty we do that
as a matter of fact that's one of the
hardest things
i think about changing the um
set list around from one year to the
next always taking some things out
taking some things out and then putting
new things in
but it's always when you run across a
song that's like
man that was that was that was a great
song and that
song meant a lot to a lot of people
it was just my imagination exactly
telling lies
bruh i would do i used to listen to like
the most sentimental [ __ ] in the gym
i would be just and i was doing steroids
in high school i'm doing steroids just
people were like is it the steroids is
it the music what is going on bro get it
together
oh music is a powerful thing it really
is huh
it's amazing to have something that can
almost just be a key in it
and some days it doesn't do it a song
doesn't do it sometimes that's right but
sometimes you'll have heard it a hundred
times you might even liked it and then
you'll hear that one time and it just
like
fits every little groove yeah man that's
it's the thing man
music is a very very powerful force
and uh it never ceases to amaze me how
powerful it is
in some people's lives i've had people
man i can only imagine
they could write they come up to me and
they say man when you wrote that song
you must have been reading my mail
because that's exactly what i've been
feeling for a long time
and i just didn't know how to put it
into words but you did in a
three and a half minute song you you
said everything i've been wanting to say
that's that's powerful do you feel like
it's a gift from because sometimes i
feel like i like to do a lot of words
and talk about stuff and
uh but do you feel like it's a gift from
god or do you feel like it's something
you've created
no like you're just like a vessel kind
of i have i have
and i have no reason in the world to
understand
why i got that gift
i have no reason in the world to
understand why
uh he picked me but
thank god he did you know i mean it's
you got to accept it
it's been great yeah it's been it's been
great because
i've i've loved music all my life and
then to have the opportunity to
play it and sing it and perform it and
write it
for a living a really good living
over all these years and provide for my
family with it
man that's it's the best it's the best
doing what you love
absolutely i got one last question for
you so i heard a uh this is a rumor and
this is just like there's lore out there
there was a that
the song here's a quarter that you got
tired of playing because people would
throw quarters on stage
actually i didn't get tired of playing
it i got hit by one no way
when we first started playing that song
we were playing
small clubs so even and people would
start throwing quarters up on stage
and even if they three if they threw one
it's not gonna hurt anybody
right but when we when we start playing
theaters and you're
[Laughter]
you're third third row balcony
to throw a quarter hard enough to do
that people that are crazy as hell man
so we started getting pelted
i would look down and sorry to laugh man
it's just crazy
oh no some guy in the third row like man
i think travis needs this for you
at least i didn't have leonard skinner's
problem leonard skinner had a song
way back in the 70s called give me back
my bullets
people would throw live ammunition on
stage
oh man but this guy i was on stage
one night in uh
in knox i think it was in knoxville
tennessee and
i got hit somebody threw one from
third row balcony and it hit me right
here and i thought i'd been shot
it was just one of those things where
it's like whoa
and you kind of lose it for a second and
then
i looked down and there's
blood just streaming i got hit right
above my right eye
damn and it's just gushing blood
so i grabbed a towel and i'm trying to
stop it and i couldn't stop the bleeding
so
bottom line is it stopped the show at
the end of the show
so we had to start making an
announcement
to people it's like look you know
if you start throwing quarters and
somebody gets hurt
on stage you're actually cheating
yourself
because it's gonna put it into the show
right then
yeah and uh and it raises your ticket
price by a damn quarter
you know kinda but thankfully with venmo
now a lot of people don't have quarters
on them you know what i'm saying
yeah like if i even see a quarter i'd be
shocked sometimes
i got uh wow that's why i got larry the
cable guy
a couple of years ago to do a uh intro
for me and it's like hey y'all it's
larry cable guy
uh because of the danger involved
please do not throw quarters or any
other hard objects at the performers
during the program
otherwise i'm gonna come over your house
shove a milk bone down your throat stick
a hungry dog up behind them
that's awesome man did you ever meet
jerry clower no or even get to see him
he was probably a kid you got to meet
him i got to meet him no
way in the early days of my career
uh there was a show on uh
the nashville network which was later
became cmt
there was a show called um uh it was
ralph emery that hosted it
and uh it was nashville now
and i went on that show one night and
jerry clower was one of the other guests
and i got to meet him and he was
everything i hoped he would be man just
what a great guy and i grew up
probably the same way you did listen to
all those records that he did you know
yeah
knock him out john marcel led better
yeah
and uh in the chainsaw you know
something yeah marcel lubedale here we
go you name all of them
that's great man man i loved him was he
um
and was he was he a big was he a big
known
star when you were young kind of when
you were to your parents i'm sure your
parents loved him huh yeah
my parents my dad that's back in the
days of eight-track tape
and my dad had four or five jerry clower
eight-track tapes that he would listen
to you know from time to time of course
a bunch of country stuff thrown in there
too
but yeah and then he was on television
almost every weekend
wow he had a show that he hosted
i can't remember what network it was on
but he hosted
every week with uh jim ed brown
and he was just man he was great of
course you'd see him on he off from time
to time too yeah yeah i've been watching
a lot of hee haw inter
just some uh replays of it and stuff
yeah it's really fascinating what they
did with that show
yeah it was amazing um did uh yeah i
thought about trying to even do a
documentary about him like trying to put
it together and fund it and everything
you know
just before because i know his wife is
still alive so before like some of that
disappears you know
just trying to find a way to memorialize
some of it there's a lot of that that i
think needs to be that's one of the
biggest reasons why
i like to
recall and recollect i'm going to write
a book
at some point i did one a few years ago
but
i want to write another one and just
tell all of the stories
that i've experienced and and heard
about
throughout the years about all of my
heroes the people that came before me
waylon jennings charlie daniels oh yeah
willie nelson
uh you got to have those things because
they'll go away even you know
exactly they'll go away if you don't
tell them they do go away
yeah and there's nobody else that knows
those stories but me
amen amen and them yeah and the lord
baby
well we got to hold on to what we can
anything else uh sean
you feel good uh travis man thank you so
much for being here with us today thank
you so much for honor man
thank you for for uh yeah i think
keeping nostalgia and just keeping my
feelings alive throughout my life i
think that's
something that you and a lot of
entertainers of of your ilk have done
man
well thank you it's a real value to be
able to
just someone who kind of is running like
a it's almost like you're just running
this stitch every now and then through
time that kind of holds people
just close enough to the world that
they're in that makes them feel a part
of something you know well i appreciate
you listening and i appreciate the fact
that
uh you were able to recognize something
in some of the music that i did that
that touched your heart and that's good
yeah thank you man i appreciate that
yeah the one uh
about the uh what was in the spell man i
used to
i couldn't even spell and i was singing
it all the time t-r-o-u-b-l-e
oh no no that one you made that one easy
for me
but no it's a i'm gonna be somebody oh
yeah i remember dude i remember being in
spelling class i'm thinking man i'm
gonna hear that song i'm gonna be
somebody someday
and i'll be like i'm gonna gonna dance
i wouldn't dude i was getting the effing
spelling bro but in [ __ ] the hope and
my hard dog i had an a plus
there you go man man travis [ __ ] thank
you so much for being here thank you
thea
[Music]
that is where daddies and mamas
were saints what preachers were
preaching
you could take to the bank
kids playing outside up until
it turned dark when the world
turned slow and you could smoke in a
ball
[Music]
trucks took a beating the working man
too you could turn on six o'clock
and get the whole truth a seed belt was
a backup
for mama's right arm when the world
turned slower and you could smoke
you